could you please not drive a wedge  between employer and employee hold on i  thought we were partners look i came up  short okay i had to buy her a prom dress  you want me to deny her a prom dress  might as well you denied her a prom date  no i offered to take her and chaperone  nobody wants to go to the dance with  their dad it's weird it's not the issue  well maybe it should be sweetheart your  shorts are shrinking by the second okay  nobody understands the cloud it's a  mystery  look all that's happened here is there's  been a very minor sinking mishap this is  not minor you know what annie  i'm on there too nobody cares about you  nobody wants to watch you having sex you  said it yourself  friends building is close go through the  business district stay away from the  gangs downtown  do they look like just apes to you  dad  what are you doing dad oh come on  it's okay  oh  okay